all right all right here we are
final session of the day
i hope you're all as excited and filled
with energy as i am
i only joke of course i am super excited
to be here on this slightly wobbly stage
i'm not gonna try to think about that
too much about the pit below
alright so i'm here to talk about web
components
what they are how to use them
and what role they will play in the
future of web development
my name is tobias and i am from
gothenburg in the west of sweden
uh here i work as a web developer
consultant
and also part-time as a front-end
evangelist at the company squead
and i will also of course take this
opportunity to mention that we do have
oslo offices and indeed we are actively
hiring right now
but i am here today to evangelize then
as we say about web components
first though let's take a little step
back
and
i want to talk about an amazing
invention that makes our lives so much
easier every day
i am talking about
ice delivery
what a fantastic service right you get
ice right to your door you can put it in
your icebox to keep your food cold so it
doesn't spoil if it's a hot day you can
grab the old ice pick and
chop off some pieces and put them in
your drink
what would we do without ice delivery
except of course no one has ice delivery
anymore
everyone has refrigerators of course
and the reason why is obvious
a fridge is in every way more convenient
it's cheaper for the customers in the
long run
electricity is a lot easier to deliver
than big blocks of ice
uh when you buy a house or an apartment
the fridge is usually there already
waiting for you
you might even call the electricity a
built-in or maybe a native feature of
the house
so even though a lot of ice delivery
people unfortunately had to find new
jobs
moving to refrigerators was clearly an
upgrade for everyone involved
and you know what else upgrades
the web
all the time
sometimes it feels like hardly a day
goes by without some new web tech being
announced and hyped up
but one of the most amazing things about
the web i think is it's backwards
compatibility
even though new things are added to the
specifications all the time
the old stuff still works
if it didn't then suddenly a lot of old
web pages would just stop working
everyone would have to constantly
upgrade and maintain their existing
sites
nothing else would get done
so the backwards compatibility of the
web is truly an amazing feature
let's take a look at another technology
jquery what a fantastic library am i
right
when it came around a few years ago in
2006 it was a tremendous upgrade from
the way we used to query and manipulate
the dom
it made web development easier and in
the end it allowed us to create better
experiences for our users
but not many people use jquery anymore
while it's still in use a lot it exists
in a lot of places but it's hardly the
first thing you reach for when you're
starting a new project these days
like you would have done maybe 10 years
ago
and this is because many of the features
and good practices that estab was
established by jquery made it into the
javascript and css specifications and
thus became native browser features
the functionality that jquery provided
became obsolete
now we're able to do many of the things
jquery did but without having to ship a
bundle of jquery code to the users
they already have everything they need
natively in their web browsers
and so while the transition away from
jquery to new things may have been a
little cumbersome in the end
it was an upgrade for everyone involved
a little bit like how ice delivery was
replaced by built-in electricity
now let's talk about a technology that
many of us probably use quite a lot
javascript frameworks what fantastic
technology am i right
and i'm talking here about the mostly
client-side frameworks like react or
view etc
these programs do so much for us and
they enable us to build so many cool
things
and there are many problems that these
frameworks help us solve
like they help us keep state and ui in
sync we update the state the framework
automatically updates the ui
we never have to write a dom modifying
line of code again the frameworks do all
this for us and they do it very well
they also help us with another important
thing componentization
as good programmers we want to
structure our code by speed splitting it
splitting it up into
logical reusable chunks of code
i'm sure you know all about the
advantages of this
but since there hasn't been a native
solution for this on the web we've had
to resort to things like template
engines and javascript tooling to be
able to write componentized code on our
end
and then the browser receives a
packaged and bundled and transpiled
version of this code that the browser
can run
and
this puts a distance between the code
that we write
and the code that the user runs
and the bigger this distance the less
control and understanding we actually
have of what happens in our applications
and the harder it becomes to ship
reliable code
but as long as the tools are reliable
and they are reliable
we still benefit greatly from the
componentization that these frameworks
enable us
and then there are also additional uh
problems solved by the frameworks like
css encapsulation or single page routing
and so on
the front-end frame frameworks are not
without the drawbacks of course uh there
can be a lot of domain-specific
knowledge that you need to acquire in
order to understand and work efficiently
with your framework
and while rare they can of course have
ship bugs of their own
which you have very little control over
and then on the user side we have to
include the framework runtime along with
our application specific code
which increases the total amount of data
that needs to be downloaded and so on
this has its own set of negative
consequences i'm not going to get into
that now
some frameworks minimize or mitigate
this in different ways but we always
have to ship something extra
enter then web components
web components are not a magical
solution to every aspect of web
development
but we will be able to leverage the
power of componentization on a native
level
this means that in some circumstances
front-end frameworks might not be
necessary at all
sometimes you might find that a
combination of technologies produce the
best results
but i'll talk more about the use cases
later
let's take a closer look at what web
components actually are
web components are not actually just one
thing but it is a collection of browser
apis that we collectively call web
components
the first of these apis that we'll take
a look at is html templates
so
let's imagine we have uh say a news page
right uh and we want to display news
news articles on this one
and every little article follows the
same pattern and has the same markup
uh it might look like uh might look like
this
a list of news articles
and they're wrapped in article tags and
each of these has a header and some
content
and we repeat this for each news item we
want to display
nothing weird there
but of course when there is new news we
don't want to go in and manually edit
this html document
so what we do we would do is maybe
render this page on the server
the server would get the news articles
from somewhere a database or cms or
something
and then calculate the resulting html
and send it back to the requesting user
uh works great even though there's some
extra calculating time on the server
and you have to do this for each
individual page
another thing we could do is to
pre-calculate the html document so that
there is no extra time spent on the
server at all
and the user gets a full complete
document right away this is usually
achieved with some form of static site
generator
and requires one kind of templating
language or other
also whenever there is a new new news
article new news to display
we would have to regenerate these
documents uh before the users can
request them so this is not the best
strategy if the data updates very
frequently like if there's only seconds
between updates or maybe even faster
and of course we can solve it with
front-end frameworks that we've already
mentioned we send a minimal html page
and a script bundle and then the script
fetches the data doing a loading
animation in the meantime
and then when the data arrives it
renders itself
so these are different ways to solve
this little problem but with html
templates we now have an additional
option
here's how we can do it with html
templates
right here in our html we can wrap a
bunch of markup in the template tag
everything between these tags will not
be displayed on the page but they will
still be available in the dom
so what we've wrapped in the template
tag here is the repeating part of our
news page the the list item and the
article
in order to repeat and populate the page
with these items we now have to use a
little bit of
javascript here's a script on the same
page
these first two lines just gets two
elements the list which we will be
putting the news articles into
and the template element
we then take our data which in a real
scenario would come from a backend
somewhere
and then for each news item in the data
we do the following
first of all we clone the template
because there is a clone of this kind
that we can append to the dom so that it
becomes visible
but before we make it visible we modify
it by finding the header and paragraph
and inserting some content a title and
some text
and then finally we append the clone to
the list
we do this for each data item and we get
a news page with individual news
articles
using html templates we can reuse html
code using only native browser apis
we could have done the same without
templates
some of you might be thinking this
by just directly inserting creating and
inserting dom nodes for every iteration
but a html template is
one more performant
and two it makes use of the declarative
nature of html making the code more
easily readable
and what you write is closer to what
will be what will be rendered in the dom
in the end
custom elements is the second of the
apis that make up web components
if you take a html document and write a
tag that doesn't exist
like this tag here coder greeting
you get nothing
if you put some text content in the
contents in it the browser might treat
it like a div or a span or something i
think it depends on the browser i'm
actually not sure
but it's invalid html and should not be
used like that
however with custom elements we can make
this code valid
creating a custom element is done with
the custom elements registry
to define a new custom element
which is what we do down at the end here
we give the define method a name
that will later allow us to write an
html tag with that name
we also give it a class which contains
all the inner workings of the
element because it is with javascript's
class syntax that we
specify what our custom elements shall
do
we create a class that first of all
extends the built-in class html element
this is required for all custom elements
and then in the constructor here we set
the the element's inner text to hello
world
and that's that now we can write a coder
greeting tag here in the html and we get
our greeting on the screen
and that's how simple it can be to
create your own custom element
in fact it might not be possible to do
it any simpler
let's also take a quick look at
attributes
any attribute put on the html tag can be
retrieved in the code with the get
attribute method
and then used in the element
so if we put the attribute name on the
html tag here
we can then retrieve it in the component
clause
and in this case we make it part of the
element's inner text
and so we get hello ndc
and there's tons more you can do with
these and we'll actually get more into
that in a minute
but just remember that the api for a
custom element
is the same like that of a regular
element things like get attribute set
attributes all these things
they're all there
finally the third api that powers web
components is the shadow dom
now i don't know if it's the name of it
or what
but i've gotten the impression that this
is like the most
the scariest and most difficult thing
about web components to grasp but i
don't think it is very complicated
really so let's take a look
here we have a visualization of a very
small document tree
we got an html node at the root
and then some html elements nested below
nothing strange about this all is normal
perfectly ordinary website
now you know that we can use javascript
to attach new nodes to this tree
that's nothing new but what we can do is
we can take one of these elements and
attach a so-called shadow root to it
attaching a shadow root to the body
element would make a tree look like this
this doesn't affect the tree in any way
yet but we can now attach more regular
nodes to the shadow root
like this
and what we have here is actually a new
separate tree
just like the regular tree has the html
node as its root
this new tree has the shadow root node
as its root
and what the shadow root also does is
that it acts like a kind of gatekeeper
between the shadow tree and the light
tree the shadow world and the light
world we got a gate between those two
let's say for instance that we put a
style tag somewhere in the in the light
tree
uh a regular style tag for some styling
this styling does not penetrate through
the shadow roots nothing within the
shadow world can be targeted by that css
and the same goes for styling decide
defined inside the shadow world
nothing in the light world will be able
to be targeted
you also can't query for elements across
the border if you use
documents.queryselector you will not
find anything
that exists on the other side of the
shadow root
you will have to find the shadow root
itself and then use
shadowroot.queryselector if you want to
find things inside the shadowboard
there are ways to pierce the shadow
boundary and have things like styling
come through but we'll talk more about
that in a little while for now just know
that the shadow dom is a separate
document tree that encapsulates its
behavior
and does not affect the rest of the
document
okay now we
we have looked at html templates custom
elements and the shadow dom and so
with our powers combined we now have the
ability to create web components
so let's do exactly that
the component that we will be coding is
a custom checkbox
something you might often find in
component libraries
since native checkboxes are notoriously
hard to style
uh it's actually got gotten a little
easier recently but to make them truly
custom you still have to do all the work
yourself
so the first thing we'll do is create
our custom element
we'll call it cool checkbox because
obviously it's going to be really cool
and we'll extend html element just like
we're supposed to
next we'll define a function called
connectedcallback
you might remember before we specified
the component's content in the
constructor
now a problem with doing that is that it
won't work if the element is appended to
the dom before it has been defined
and this is something that you might
want to avoid anyway
but just to be safe
and to follow best practices it is best
to do all of the initial dominant
manipulation and setup in the connected
callback function
because this function runs right after
the element has been both defined and
then placed in the dom so it is the
ideal place for setting up everything
that the component needs uh its initial
state so to speak
so in this function we set the elements
inner html to be an input of type
checkbox and the corresponding label
and then finally we define our element
in the custom elements registry and it's
ready to use
we can now put it in our html file like
so
and we get a perfectly ordinary checkbox
awesome
so uh let's make this web component a
little cooler
let's use a html template for the
content of our component
before we defined a template
declaratively in the html file
like this you remember
but we can also do it imperatively with
javascript
so that's what we do here we use
document.createelement
to create a template element
and then we set its inner html
and then down in the connected callback
we clone the template content using
document.import node
and append it to our element
and voila it looks exactly the same as
before
however the advantage is that if we put
multiple instances of our component on a
page
the template will only have to be parsed
once
and then it can be reused via cloning
so the more copies you have on a page
and the more complex they are the bigger
the performance gain will be
all right so this was going to be a cool
shake box and since there's nothing
cooler than being dark and mysterious so
i've been told
let's add a shadow dom
this is done in the constructor
and it's no harder than taking our
element and calling attach shadow on it
and there now we have a shadow root on
our custom element
you can
we also pass an options object that
contains mode open
and this is so that the shadow root will
allow us to access it with javascript
from the outside
uh you will probably always do this
set it to open when you create your
shadow roots because it is by accessing
it with javascript that we can
manipulate its content
and that's actually something that we
immediately do here in the connected
callback function
here instead of appending the cloned
template
content to the element itself we append
it to the shadow root instead
and now we have a shadow dom
all of the html content from the
template that was appended to the shadow
root is now living in its own little
shadow world
having a good old time
if we take a look at the page structure
in the browser dev tools
this is from firefox
we can see the shadow root clearly on
display
pretty much like a regular node in the
tree
we can expand it
and under each node is a copy of our
template
with this with this it within its own
little shadow dome
some styles to the checkbox is as easy
as adding it to the template
we can put a style tag here and some css
inside that makes the label pink
and
as you may notice we're using a very
broad selector here just label right
if this was in the light on we might not
want to use such broad selectors but
instead use classes and ids and things
to be more specific and target specific
elements
but since the styles inside the shadow
dom only affects the elements inside the
shadow dom
we don't have to make it more
complicated than this we only have two
elements as you can see the input and
the label
also note that the id on the checkbox is
super generic just checkbox
ids are also encapsulated in the shadow
rom so there will be no id conflicts if
elements in the light dome or in other
shadow domes
have the same id
this allows us to write css that is this
simple
we rarely have to bother with
classes and you know naming
methodologies css strategies
if we can keep the markup in our
template simple we can keep css simple
and keeping things simple is pretty much
half our jobs right
so here is the effect very pink just
like the css set
okay so a webcam component can do a lot
when it comes to deciding its own
content
but it wouldn't be very versatile if the
user couldn't affect the content and
appearance of the component
and there are multiple ways to achieve
this
one way is using slots
this is a concept that will be very
familiar to you if you've worked with
vue
it's also not unlike the concept of
children in react
what a slot is is a place in the
template that we allow the user to fill
with content
we place the slot tags anywhere we want
in the template like right there
and then we put something between the
tags of our custom element it can be
text like this but it can also be any
valid html so there's really no limit to
this
and the result is that whatever we put
between the element tags ends up inside
inside the slot tax
so it's pretty simple right
it's also possible to have multiple
slots and then the user needs to
or then you have to give the slots names
and then the user
must use the corresponding names to
place different pieces of content into
different slots so that's also possible
the next way to give data to our
component is by using attributes and
properties
important to know the difference between
an attribute and a property to
understand this
an attribute is what we set on an html
tag
we can then access this attribute with
javascript but it will always be a
string
a property is what we have on a
javascript object
and as you may know when it comes to the
dom the document object model
each element in html is represented by a
javascript object
and this is what we what we get when we
use things like a query selector
and this object has properties that we
can access and change just like any
other javascript object and then the
html is also updated
so let's say we want to set the text of
a label
via an attribute instead of a slot
uh this makes sense in a way because
a label should probably just be a piece
of text right well if we set the
attributes on the cool checkbox tags in
the html like this
that doesn't mean we automatically get a
property on the corresponding js object
we actually have to do that ourselves so
that's what we do here in the connected
callback function
we get the attribute
and we set it on the element
so that was pretty easy
but remember the connected callback
function only runs once when the element
is inserted into the dom
what if the user changes the attribute
that's where this next lifecycle method
comes into play attribute changed
callback
as the name implies this method fires
anytime one of our attributes is changed
and we can then update the property
accordingly
uh it's actually not quite the whole
truth i should say
this method runs whenever one of our
observed attributes change and the
observed attributes are the ones
returned by the getter function that you
see here static get observed attributes
if any attribute in this list changes
then the attribute changed callback will
run
and this is because there is you know no
no limit to what attributes
you can put on an html html element
you could put whatever you want
so this ensures that we don't run a
bunch of code just because of a change
to something that we don't even care
about
all right so now whenever the label
attribute is set or changed the property
will be updated sync achieved
but what about the other direction
if we use javascript to change the
property directly
we also want the attribute in the html
to update right
and even more importantly which is which
we haven't done yet we want the actual
text on the page to change
this is not something that happens
automatically either
so let's make it happen
the easiest way to accomplish this i
think
is to use a custom getter and setter for
our property this is all part of the
class syntax probably familiar to you
the getter for the property is very
simple it just returns the value of the
attribute
and then the setter does a little more
whenever we set the property label
this code is going to run and the first
thing it does is it checks if the new
value of label exists at all
if not then we reflect that change by
removing the attribute from the html
altogether
but if the property does indeed have a
value then we set the label attribute to
this value and we also update the inner
html so that the change appears visually
in the browser
now the label attribute and property are
all wired up they stay in sync and they
behave as expected
we use it like this with a couple of
different labels there and it appears
just the way we want
all right so the final way of letting
the user affect the content and behavior
of our web component is by piercing the
shadow boundary
i mentioned this earlier the shadow dom
and the light on are separate but there
are controlled ways to let information
slip through and that's what we're going
to explore now
first of all i'll just add a bunch of
css here to make the checkboxes really
custom
we won't go closer into this because
because how to style the checkbox that's
pretty much a session in its own
but there is one interesting part of
these css that you won't find in the
light world the host sudo selector
this selector targets the host element
that is in our case the actual cool
checkbox element itself
the container for the whole custom
element really
one reason for targeting this can be to
avoid having to use unnecessary wrappers
on the top level because the element is
a wrapper in itself
anyway this is what it looks like um now
the checkboxes are truly cool uh
especially when compared to this sad
little regular old checkbox hanging out
beside
so notice the text color black right
well take a look at this css declaration
here we set the text color of the label
to that of a css custom property
but this property isn't declared
anywhere so the color just
reverts to its default state
and
when it comes to text color it is an
inherited value
meaning it is set to the computed value
of its parent
and that's why we only have to set
things like color and um
and font family uh once usually up on
the body element right
and then this is inherited throughout
our entire document
and the reason why i bring this up is
because inheritance
is one way to pierce the shadow boundary
inherited values inherit through to the
shadow dom
so if your page uses a certain typeface
your web component will automatically
get the same typeface applied to them
without the need to specify this for
each and every component
but what about this custom property then
why is it there at all
well custom properties are another way
to pierce the shadow boundary and it's a
very controlled one
the custom properties that we use in our
internal css here in our component they
become the api
for the users if they want to change and
affect the internal styling of the
component
so we can do it like this
this is out in the light world
somewhere in the top of the document
and we have some styling here that sets
this custom property
cool checkbox label color
and when we set it out here in the light
world it is then picked up by the css
inside the shadow world and the text
turns green
and since custom properties can be
they can represent you know pretty much
any
value in css
big or small and they can be reused in
many ways
custom properties provide a quite
powerful api that we can expose to our
users allowing them to customize pretty
much anything we want
okay so we've looked at how a user can
send data into the web component to
affect things
and now the final thing i want to show
you is how to send data from the web
component back up to the user
and this is done using the good old
browser api
events it might look like this for
instance in the connected callback
function uh we find something to react
to in this case it's our checkboxes
change event but you know it could be
like it could be a bottom press it could
be a network call
completion anything really
and then what we do is we dispatch a new
event on the custom element
notice that it's not on the shadow root
but we dispatch the event on the element
itself
and then the user can then
attach event listeners to the custom
element
and
react to these to these elements being
dispatched
and it's it's really that simple that's
how we send data back up
uh if you're not 100 familiar with the
the event api
uh know that in this in addition to
dispatching an event with a name you can
also include any kind of data that the
listener can make use of
so we can send
both notified that something has
happened and we can send complementary
data up to the user
okay so this concludes the creation of
our checkbox web component
we're using a custom element with a
shadow dom that encapsulates styles
we're accepting user data via attributes
and css custom properties and we're
sending data back up with custom events
there are of course loads more advanced
stuff you can do with your web
components but this pretty much covers
the basics
i think the main thing to take away is
that it is all native browser apis and
many of these
you are probably already familiar with
so hopefully that will make the step to
start using web components a little
smaller
so
now that we've talked about how to
create web component let's talk a little
bit about how to use them in different
environments and scenarios
putting a web component in a regular
website is as easy as running its
registration script once and then
placing it in the html this is what
we've done a couple of times already in
this
presentation using web components inside
client-side frameworks
is also incredibly straightforward as
long as you run the registration code
once uh then you can just use them like
you would regular html elements it's
super easy and straightforward
the only major exception is actually
react
which cullen currently requires a thin
wrapper around the components in order
for listeners and attributes to work
correctly
but this is being worked on and it will
probably be fixed in the next release of
react
but other than that in most major
frameworks
it just works
as you've seen throughout this talk the
apis that we use to create our web
components are fairly low level right
uh there are many things that need to be
wired up manually
and this leads to a lot of boilerplate
code
wouldn't it be easier then if we could
make an abstract class that takes care
of all this boilerplate code and then we
can inherit from that instead of
inheriting directly from html element
well yes it would be and luckily there
are already
many clever people who have thought of
this and made such classes that we can
use
some have gone even further than that
and made a really complicated solutions
for creating web components
but i think it's safe to call all of
these web component frameworks
because they make it so much easier and
cleaner to write web components but
underneath they use all of the
technology that we've looked at here
today
so having that understanding will make
it easier for you
to understand and use the frameworks
here are a couple of the most popular
web component frameworks right now uh
lit is a very competent base class that
you can inherit from
it only uses native javascript syntax
and yet manages to make the api very
streamlined it's a sort of continuation
of the polymer project which you may
have heard of
so i highly recommend checking this out
it's probably the most popular web
component framework right now
stencil
includes tooling that makes it easy to
write
collections or libraries of web
components
they also use jsx in their syntax so if
you're coming from react you might feel
comfortable there
and if you're going to create the whole
library of web components this is
definitely
a library a framework you can consider
and there are also many others out there
like solid or lightning or hybrids for
example and many more
there are also uh
some of our
should i call them traditional
client-side javascript frameworks that
can actually compile their components
into web components uh such as vue or
svelt
i will admit that i haven't actually
explored this very much myself uh but
the possibility is there just so you
know
in conclusion when it comes to web
component frameworks
you will probably want to use one of
these when you write web components
at least if you need a moderate amount
of complexity or more
they do make things a lot easier and
they don't add a lot of overhead
but again having an understanding of how
web components work on a fundamental
level will make it easier to understand
what the frameworks do and it will make
you a better developer in the long run i
dare say
okay we are nearing the end of this talk
so let's take a moment to look to the
future and ask ourselves what role will
web components play in the future of web
development
web components are mature enough and has
enough browser support to be used in
production today
and they are being used in production in
many places
some people already use web components
to build entire complex
web apps
other use them to build single
universally usable components that can
be distributed and used in any context
i'd like to show you a couple of
examples actually of
standalone web components that are
really quite extraordinary and i know
they would have taken me a long time to
build
this is a component by github called
relative time you give it a timestamp
and it outputs a nice relative time like
five minutes ago or two hours from now
yeah you've all seen this
amazingly reusable i love this component
and this one two up you give it two html
elements
and they can then be compared with a
sliding overlay effect so it's perfect
for you know before and after photos or
other kinds of comparisons uh anything
you can think of really cool stuff
and how about this one model viewer you
give it the url to a 3d file and bam
just like that you've got an interactive
3d model right there in the browser how
amazing is that
i don't even know how amazing it is
because i wouldn't know where to start
with something like this but this is all
encapsulated in a single web component
super cool
another popular use for web components
is as i've already mentioned to build ui
libraries with them possibly as part of
a larger design system
this makes the library components
universal and doesn't force any specific
technology on the users of the library
this is especially useful in very large
organizations where
multiple tech stacks already exist
or where experimentation with new
technologies are allowed and encouraged
so you won't have to throw away your
entire code base or
avoid using the library
because the technologies don't match
or if you want to do you know a side
project with svelte instead of react
at your
at your job
if the ui library is made with web
components you can use them anyway
a question i hear asked is will web
components replace javascript client
frameworks
some might claim that web components are
here to completely replace or distort
the javascript ecosystem
will it be so
well not very soon i don't think there
are still a lot of problems that these
frameworks solve that web components in
and of themselves do not
not to mention the huge communities and
ecosystems that surround these
frameworks
but you could ask yourself this
will react and similar frameworks
last and be popular forever
like forever ever
probably not
uh so what will replace them
and when
well regardless of what mine or your
predictions are the fact is
that web components are part of the web
specification
and that's not going away
because remember the web is backwards
compatible
in fact the specification will only keep
evolving and improving as time goes by
so sooner or later it might be time for
you to
to upgrade
thank you
if you want to get in touch with me uh
my website is there to be
assumingstrom.net and you can find me on
twitter as well
yeah that's it it's been a delight thank
you so much